welcome everyone to this topic
on docker networking here so in this one
we are going to talk about
that what exactly is in docker uh why
the docker networking is
important uh what is the docker
networking all about
features of docker networking container
network modes
uh network drivers and then we will be
having a demo
on creating a bridge connector a bridge
network and we will see that how we can
run our custom docker container
on that custom docker network so let's
go ahead with this
activity what is the docker all about so
docker is an
os level virtualization software
platform which helps the user to develop
deploy and manage and run applications
inside a docker container
now the best part about this is that not
only you store the source code
you also put up the dependencies inside
it so if i have a java based application
so apart from the java code base i will
also be putting up the
dependencies like jdk and also inside
the docker container
so it's a complete package which you're
going to prepare and inside this package
you will be having all the dependencies
and whatever the binaries
you require you will be having it inside
a docker container
now if you see the diagram over here you
have a infrastructure
on top of which you have the host
operating system then
on top of the host operating system you
have the docker engine
now docker engine is the main component
here which takes up
all the requests which make sure that
all the containers are up and running
and it actually gives an interface or
kind of a run time to the docker
containers
so that they can run their specific
applications so this is a basic
component basic architecture of the
docker
now docker container is a very
lightweight software package okay
usually inside these docker containers
you will be having all the dependencies
all the software packages everything is
included in this site these docker
containers
so it's a complete package if i'm
looking forward for a jenkins
application container
in there everything will be there right
from the base operating system to the
jdk
and then on top of that the jenkins
application running
there so the moment i go there and run
the docker container of jenkins
i will be able to have a full-fledged
jenkins application available
which i can access through the url and
through a specific port 8080
so docker container is a kind of a
package where both the dependencies
and the source code and the libraries
are available why exactly the
docker networking is important let's
talk about some scenario over here so
my application is something which
totally works perfectly fine into my
system and there is no issues on there
i ran it perfectly fine and i got the
resmarts i'm able to interact everything
i'm able to do
but the same application does not works
on the other person's
system now what could be the issue
because it's working on one machine and
it's not working on another machine
now the application does not work on
another system because
there is a difference in the computer
systems maybe one system is having a
different machine and another system is
having a different machine and
you may be having some of the
differences maybe in the
uh term of hardware maybe in the terms
of software
so the differences are possible in two
different machines so how we can
get a solution that we don't get this
kind of problems
and once the container is prepared it
should be able to run it across
different systems so
docker networking is the ideal solution
for this
uh problem over here with docker
networking the application works totally
fine
and it's something which can work on any
system you don't have any dependency
that
it will run only on a specific machine
or a particular system
so what exactly is in docker networking
all about so docker networking
enables a user to link a docker
container to as many as networks
you know he or she requires so you can
actually connect a docker container to a
specific network
the docker networks are used to provide
complete isolation to the docker
containers
so you can have it like okay i want to
run some couple of containers in a
different network
and another containers i want to run it
into a different networks
so you can do that isolations and the
whole purpose of doing that isolation is
so that we will be able to have a proper
networking and proper
executions and all that stuff so docker
networking is a very important concept
when we talk about
or when we come up with the interaction
on having the docker containers
isolated so it resolves most of the
problems okay
so um you can have like a multiple
containers
in running in same network you can have
a different
particular networks also there so a
specific network
have its own attributes and then you can
use those attributes to
connect to that containers and to access
that containers
but the whole idea is that the
containers are something which is
uh specifically running in a set of
servers or in a set of
platform so whenever i'm trying to look
forward to
that particular container it has to be
there into a
network if you don't run it into your
custom network
then whatever the default network
present it will be
hosted in that network there so how does
the docker networking
actually works so you got a decker file
so using the dockerfile you got up
a custom docker image and from this
docker image you have to
actually go there and uh you know put up
like the docker container so
um you can also store this docker image
to the docker hub so that
the same docker image can be shared
across different users and they can also
pull down their docker image and they
can have the container running in their
systems
so for the collaborating the docker
image you require the docker hub and
the container is the ultimate thing or
object which we need to create
out of the docker image when we go with
the
particular process when the whole
process goes on over there
so what happens that the instead of the
docker hub you can use your own private
repositories also
that's something which totally relies
onto you that how exactly
those things works on so a docker file
creates a docker image using the build
command
a docker image contains all the project
source code all the dependencies
uh using this docker image you can
actually run the source code in order to
get
a docker container the moment you
initialize or running stance of docker
image
you will be able to get a darker
container you can actually use the
docker hub for collaborating or for
sharing the docker image
so you can store the docker image on
docker hub and then different people can
actually go ahead and download or pull
this docker image onto their system and
they can also run their
specific containers so what are the
different advantages
we get with the docker networking very
first one is a rapid
deployment portability better efficiency
a faster configuration
scalability and the security over here
so these are some of the advantages
which we get when we talk about the
docker networking here now let's talk
about the container
network model here so what is the
network model we are looking forward
from the containers perspective
now this is a kind of architecture here
now in this one let's see that how it
actually works on now you have a docker
engine which
is a main component which takes up all
the things and all the
important components are actually
integrated with each other now the
network sandbox
is the one in which you will be having
your container running up and running
now every network is having its own
attributes
the uh particular different gateway ips
the ip addresses
the range of ipads the cidr blocks also
everything it can be different to
for two different networks so the whole
point is that you will be defining
okay if you don't define that i want to
run this uh particular container into a
specific network
then definitely that's going to run into
a default network which is
which gets created the moment you do the
installation of dockers but
anyhow any network is required for
running a docker container
so there are different network drivers
which is available there
so if you feel that you want to create a
network so you have to choose a
particular networking or the
connectivity over there
and uh it really helps us to understand
how the configurations
and how the different modifications and
those changes can be really done here
so a lot of changes are actually going
on and uh you know performing there and
this really helps us to understand that
how
the things are being done as such over
there so
network is something which is very
important from the containers
perspective
so the network sandbox isn't kind of a
isolated sandbox that holds the all the
network configurations of the containers
so you will be requiring a at least one
docker
container network if you want to run a
container inside in that particular
sandbox
so sandbox is created when a user
requests to generate an endpoint on the
network
so that's where the sandbox gets created
uh it can have severals and points in a
network
as it represents a containers network
configurations like ip address mac
address dns name
so every container will be having its
own unique ip address right
so that can be a particular endpoint to
connect to that container and it can
have it like different
uh endpoints and different different
networks so that's always the
possibilities which is available there
now the end points uh establishes the
connectivity for
the container services with other
services also so the moment you work on
the
uh particulars uh endpoints so that can
be used for
having okay there is a service running
in a container so how you can do that
so if you in order to connect that you
require these endpoints
so that you can establish the
connectivity with the container services
whatever running
inside these docker containers
right now the network is something which
provides the specific
underlining network attributes like the
networking support to the docker
containers
because these uh network sandbox boxes
will definitely have
a requirement of the network so how
you're going to get that
that you will be only able to get when
you go okay i will be looking forward
for the connectivity and i can go for
the
communications and i can give the
hardware because although it's a os
level virtualization but still you
require some interaction with the
hardware from the
networking perspective and then docker
engine is a
the base engine which is installed on
the host machine
and it's actually the main component
which make sure that the docker
containers
and the corresponding docker services
are always up and running
and the uh using the network drivers you
can actually create multiple
networks onto your system and you can
have those uh configurations
now the network architecture is
something which helps us to provide
the connectivity among the endpoints
that probably belongs to the same
network and
uh it's something which is a kind of
isolated network
so different different networks can be
isolated uh networks and we can have the
end points to them
so uh there are different ways in which
we can establish the connectivity and
this is a complete network architecture
which is there so you have a network
drivers
you have the networks you have the
network sandboxes in which internally
the
docker containers are running and then
these network sandboxes are having their
respective endpoints there to access
them to establish the connectivity
now let's talk about the network drivers
now there are five
type of network drivers which is
available first one is the bridge
host none overlay and mac
vlan so these are the different uh
particular network drivers which is
available over here
uh first one is a bridge it's a private
default network
created on the host if you go there if
you go to
the installation of a docker this is the
default driver which gets installed onto
the system
onto the host the containers linked to
this network
will have an internal ip address through
which we they can actually communicate
with each other
on the same machine also you can
establish the connectivity you can
connect to the containers using that
private ip address
but outside the server you will not be
able to have the communication
but internally you can connect to the
containers and containers can also
interact with each other
they can also communicate with each
other with this one uh the docker
daemon creates the uh docker zero so if
you run the
ipconfig config or if config on the
system
you will be able to see a docker zero
kind of ethernet
bridge network which is created using
which you can see that okay this is the
network which is created by default
it's a default installation or default
configuration which
automatically happens the moment you set
up a docker instance
so you don't have to go into the
configurations or in the setup of there
it will be already available on that
particular installation board there
and the next one is the host one so it's
a public network so when we go with the
public network it's
actually uses the host iprs and tcp port
in order to interact with the service
running inside the docker container
so if you are looking forward that i
want to reach out or i want to connect
to the
container but i want to use an ip
address which can be accessible from
outside world probably some other server
should be able to resolve that
in that situation the host network
driver comes into the picture
so it uh effectively disables the
network isolation
between the docker host and the docker
containers which means
that using this driver a user can
actually run multiple containers
you know it's it's not possible for the
user to run multiple containers
on the same host because of the fact
that you are using
the host ip address now when we were
talking about the bridge connection at
that moment of time
we were getting the private ip addresses
which was totally
isolated and totally unique so there
were actually if you create a using the
bridge connection multiple containers
so you will see that if there are five
three containers everyone will be having
a different private ip address but the
moment you go for the host one so in
that situation
the ipad is not going to change so you
get some restrictions
okay because the combination is of ipads
and port
so ips and 8080 can happen only once it
cannot happen
multiple times so that's the limitation
that you cannot run multiple containers
on the same host due to this restriction
and the next one is the none so in this
network driver
the docker containers will neither have
any access to the external network
or it will not be able to communicate
with the other containers also
total isolation and total private
containers
are being done when we use this driver
so if you
these options are usually used when you
want to disable so this is not doing
nothing but disabling the total
networking
of functionality for a specific
container that's what it happening over
here
next one is overlay so this one is uh
utilized for creating an internal
private network
to the docker nodes in the docker swamp
cluster so
overlay does not comes up in case of a
standalone docker installation
the moment you go with the particular
docker swamp cluster
at that moment of time the overlay type
of network is created
so docker uh swam is an acquisition tool
so uh that requires a overlay kind of uh
driver which can you know help them to
achieve the networking in case of
cluster because
in case of docker spam you have a master
node manager node
worker nodes different different
machines are there so in that situation
overlay is the
main component or is the main type of
driver which is used
and then we have the mac vlan so it
simplifies the communication processes
between their containers
this network assigns a mac address to
the docker containers
with this mac address the docker you
know servers will route the
network traffic to our router so it's
it's not on the basis of ip address it's
actually on the basis of
mac address so uh on the specific mac
address
the network this docker server will
redirect the
network to a specific router
right it's usable when a user wants to
directly connect
the containers to the physical network
rather than the docker host so
that's where this communication works on
so it's a direct connectivity between
the
host network and the docker container so
there is
no virtualization which is happening
over here so uh it's something which is
you know giving a direct access to the
networks
but it's definitely on the basis of mac
address which on which the communication
is happening
now let's talk about the networking
implementation and we'll see that how we
can go for
a particular bridge network
implementation there so let's go back to
the virtual machine
so i am connected to a particular system
here so i can check that if the
docker is available to me and i can just
run the
docker version so it says that okay the
client and the
server component both is available there
now we are going to see that what are
the different uh
containers which is uh what are the
different docker containers network
which is available there
so i'm going to run a command called
docker network ls now the moment you do
it over here you will see that none host
and bridge these are the different
containers uh
network which is available there and uh
you can see their network ids the names
the drivers but drivers is also very
important because
that's what we are going to use here so
it's a very good one here
so the default one you can see that the
bridge is available
and uh it's a default one whenever you
create any container
by default whether you give the
container attribute or not
it's something which gets created into
the uh terms or in the
uh basis of uh the container only in the
default network only
so how we can get that we can always get
that part by
uh you know having the understanding
that what network we are using
so i'm going to run a couple of
containers a small container and we can
see that
how exactly uh the containers can be
executed and
can be done over there right so let's
see
so i'm going to run a command docker
run hyphen d id
iphone iphone name
alpine one
alpine
image is what i am going to use and
usage
so it pulls down the alpine image that's
what it happened
and the same thing i'm going to run but
this time i'm going to run
alpine 2 because i want to create two
containers
right so with this one what will happen
that i will be having
like like two containers available here
so i can say
like darker ps so i can see that two
containers that are unique one is
alpine and one is alpine two right so
now what happens that
we will see that how the connectivity
happens and what other network details
so what i'm going to do is that first of
all i'm going to do an inspect
over there onto the bridge connectivity
so that i can get the detailed
information
so this is the name of
the particular ones of the network so
this is the network which is available
and this is the default one
so if i scroll up you can see that this
is the name of the
bridge connectivity and even if you run
the docker network list
so uh you will be able to see that the
id also so id also if you compare so
uh e65 that's the one which is available
now this one is something which is using
a driver called bridge
and here you can see the subnet
information now if you scroll down you
can see that two containers are
available here
so i did not provide any kind of network
details but uh
definitely what happens that the two
containers which i deployed
are basically running inside this
network okay and you can see that uh the
bridge name docker zero is the
internet or network which gets created
uh which during the installation of
docker gets uh configured now
you can see that uh this is the ip
address this is the ip address here this
is the mac address
and this is also a mac address here so
uh the
ip address you can see this is a 3.0.3
in the last and this is dot 2 over here
so you can see that the increase the
sequence is there so alpine 1
was having an ip dot 172.17.
and alpine 2 is having an incremented
ipad as like a different one as in three
so you can see that these different ip
addresses are there
and uh represents if you want to access
them if you want to connect on them
you will be able to have the
connectivity accordingly
so even if you go inside these
containers you can actually see that
what exactly uh the connectivity you
want to establish or the connectivity
you want to
perform here right so this is the way
that how the network
usually works and uh the networks which
you are using over here is the bridge
once which
definitely helps us to understand that
how the configurations can be done
now so uh what we are going to do over
here is that we will
try to see that how exactly uh we can
uh go ahead and uh we can connect on
there and uh we can also see that if we
are able to communicate with each other
because probably uh if i run like ping
command over here
and i'll put the containers like two
and i'm able to reach out there's no
problem in reaching out to these
ips because these are the private ip
addresses and i will be able to
reach out to them without any problem
and without any concerns
so from the current uh connectivity
perspective there is no problem as such
and i have a connection available over
here but let's see
uh we'll go back to the containers we
will see that
how exactly we can talk about we can
reach out to the
one container with each other so i want
to connect alpine one with then pine two
so how we can do that
so i'm going to use like docker
fine one okay now i got a terminal
so what i can do is that i can go for
the ipa
in this show so with this one what will
happen that i will be able to know the
ipad is
so dot 2 is the one which is available
over here okay so this is the ip address
now i can simply do the uh small ping
command so i can say like ping
google.com so that will show me that if
i have an internet connectivity so
that is great so i got a connectivity
with the
internet uh over there so i will be able
to reach out any websites or any kind of
that order
now uh i have another ip so dot three is
remember we were using three front ip
so i can actually do a ping also here so
ping hyphen c
five five request will put and uh three
will do here
now we are trying to reach out to the
alpine two over there so although we are
connecting to the alpine one but we have
the connectivity with
alpine two also so from alpine one you
can connect to the alpine two containers
so that shows that since both of them
are running in the same container so
they are having the automatic
uh connectivity and you can easily reach
out to them and without any issues you
can do that
and similarly the same thing you can do
it uh in case of uh
alpine two also so you get it connected
to the alpine two and uh
you can uh just follow the same thing so
you can connect it uh with the
if you go to the alpine two you can
connect to the alpine one also
so if you come out the containers i will
be always up and running and
you will be able to have the mechanisms
there
so the whole idea about these things is
that it will be basically helping you to
understand that how
the executions can be done and how we
can perform the activities as such over
here so this is the way that how we deal
with the networkings
and how the containers gets created into
a network and then they can interact
with each other
right so this was the demo on which we
talked about that how we can talk about
a bridge network implementation with the
docker containers so that's it for this
topic
thanks
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here